[Music]
President Trump faces the historic
impeachment trial in the Senate his
campaign is looking to capitalize on the
moment the campaign emailed supporters
saying Democrats quote hyper-partisan
wasteful petty antics are why Americans
are more tuned out than they were last
year rad par scale is mr. Trump's 2020
presidential campaign manager he was
digital director for the 2016 campaign
any joint that stakes having me on
good morning good morning so I know you
guys like to talk about a landslide in
2016 if you look at it coldly yeah he
lost the popular vote and the election
swung really on less than 80,000 voters
across three states in the Midwest so
when you think about how close it was in
2016 you got this impeachment going on
now what makes you think that the
impeachment proceedings are actually
helping you grow that wall there well I
mean so first of all we measure this and
I think one of the biggest measurements
is right out of the gate is fundraising
fundraising has been up it's up 20 30
percent over the last couple months if
you actually I know that we always say
internal numbers but we have a lot of
systems for that though the Republican
National Committee has voter scores
there's polling and even public polling
now is showing the president climbing
why don't the internal numbers match the
public polling because we the latest
poll I saw was 51% supporting removal of
the president granted to CNN poll and I
want to tee you up on that subject but
you know there doesn't seem to be we are
be a disconnect we are a federal
Republican we've and we have 270 to win
and so pulling in Nashua look there's
three counties in America that you can
have millions of votes going towards the
president if you start looking at states
like North Carolina Florida Ohio
Pennsylvania Wisconsin Nevada New
Hampshire and you start looking at
pulling there the president is actually
doing very well and if you actually
measure that even approval or the ballot
versus 2016 he's doing a lot better and
the reason is he now has policies that
he's got enacted things have gone
through that he has to run on that in
2016 there are promises now the promise
is kept and that changes things
Mike Bloomberg's campaign managers said
bread is not running a national campaign
bread is running a campaign in six
states and he's doing exceptionally well
is that is that accurate
yeah I guess a first thank you for the
compliment to him it's not expecting the
compliment but I'll take it
no I think what he meant to say was
there's five six states we're focusing
on we're actually in 17 states
officially and we've been out
that we've done a off the records we've
done these things told the media but as
you look at that there's expansion
states
there's your do-or-die States you know
there's your must-have states and those
were broken into but we actually are on
the ground in 17 states yeah other
states we focus on more those are called
swing states like that for four decades
so I don't agree with his states I think
what he was trying to mean is Brad only
really needs to do great in six states
because how bad they're doing on the
other side cuz it was really tight in
those states
he doesn't seem though to be expanding
his base Brad are you concerned about
that you know the arguments you look at
the you know the focus groups I don't
know if that's actually you do a lot of
focus great would you do a lot of focus
what are you looking for in the focus
we're looking to see what's what's
actually what Americans are actually
consuming it's that's funny is if you're
in New York you're in DC and you're on
these shows there's a bubble yes there's
a big bubble you got out there and you
ask them hey what's going on impeachment
there like a piece what you know I don't
even know what's going on it's like
watching paint dry
you actually think impeachment is
helping you it does help it's the base
it excites the base remember turnouts
important there's tens of millions of
people that will show up and vote for
the president that might have showed up
look eight point eight million
disengaged in 2018 voted for chocolate
2016 didn't show up
there's millions now that are engaged to
show up and I will tell you the
president has a larger base now
significantly in 2016 but you know when
you say that it excites a base I think
the rallies excite the base to but he
stands up in the rallies you have to
admit many cases
he's very loose with the truth and so he
puts out facts he puts out he puts out
things that are absolutely not true and
that are unchallenged that fair is that
the way I think the president has a
presentation and approach that that is
talking to the American people in ways
they can assume he's very popular with
that and he is look I would disagree
with that I think the president has his
his opinion on what's happening I think
that there's a lot of the media and
we're a lot of fake news we can sit here
and argue what's true what's not I will
tell you what I think the president is
doing is help in this country right can
you sit here and say with the ads which
you have a greater hand in that those
ads are gonna be truthful we know
Facebook's gonna say they're not gonna
please the truth are you good police the
truth I think that was last year yeah I
think usually if you look back and you
look at what Facebook actually said and
you and was not
forded much and their CEO came out and
said we did not do micro-targeting
hundreds of thousands of bread
accurately Brad because there's actually
a good example of this but back during
the World Series you guys put out an ad
a campaign that and you claimed that
illegal immigration had fallen by half
and in fact it hadn't if you look at yo
they're working it up so so what do you
mean when you say you're gonna be
accurate and honest and these in these
campaigns there are look the president
has done more to curb illegal
immigration than any president we had
metrics all that stuff goes through the
iteration we have stuff you look at the
number if you actually see what what
Homeland Security said there has been a
huge takedown of those things and those
ads have backing for everything that's
in there and at the time we ran that ad
there had been a 50% decrease in illegal
immigration from month-over-month not
year of a year the app you've got money
gets locked down on it when I see Brett
you talk about fundraising and
fundraising me up the president's raise
a hundred and forty some odd million
dollars which is significantly more than
any of his Democratic challengers but
together those challengers have raid
three times as much as the president
more than three times so is that concern
you know and what's funny is that's
actually our committees to in 2019 we're
different we are in a comet we're going
through J FAS and JFC so it means we
have joint funding agreements with the
party we give a portion of our money in
our fundraising to the party none of
them are doing that we actually raised
463 million as joint committees so that
is one is the same or above them and
most of the metrics so it's it's yes did
we only put the hundred and forty
million in the deejay TFP but we also
have Trump make America great again we
have Trump victory we're running a
different campaign they're in a primary
yeah
so when you are at the accumbens are a
little different
we're already raising into multiple
buckets we don't have a primary opponent
so we did raise 463 million I'm not
worried about the president is set in
records and fundraising which Democratic
candidate are you most worried about who
gives you the most and we're building a
system that's ready for anyone but I
think Bernie is on a rise right now but
I think the media is I think he's
getting a little bit of the shaft again
right I would be surprised not surprised
that a lot of people think you would say
that because you'd like to run again I
think look I think Bernie stuff in some
of the places I think he's tough in the
in places where you know people are
making $12 an hour working out
thank you very much for being with us we
saw a stranger here about the economy we
could have a whole chat about that
you